we are back in the territory of penises
because what i said was what a
penis-rousing
honor to meet mr frankie boyle why
didn't i go with a penis
browsing is the bigger question
hello my name is tom hopper and this is
do you even know me for unilad what tom
hopper said except for instead of tom
hopper say robert sheen
there's an instagram account dedicated
to a certain feature of tom's body
which area of tom's body does this
account
celebrate all right it's i'm gonna go i
i'll happily accept half a point if one
of these answers is correct
pipes or penis it's a little bit of both
it's tom hopper's arms at tom hopper's
arms which um i have
uh yes three arms
tom fill in the blank in robert's
instagram post
when posting about meeting frankie boyle
he wrote
what a blank blank honor
what a something something honestly
what a ruddy bloody honor close
but again we are back in the territory
of penises
because what i said was what a penis
rousing honor to meet mr frankie
why didn't i go with a penis browsing is
the bigger question
please complete tom's instagram bio
dad husband blank
i was gonna say vegan you're not far off
mate
it's got something to do with food it's
dad husband
vegetable connoisseur
and and having lunch with tom hopper on
a daily basis
for many months on end that is a very
very very true statement
fill in the blank on robert's first
instagram post to all robert she and
fetishists
and friends get the blank
ready because i've just kick-started my
insta
get the blank ready more in the the
fetishists rather than the friends arena
kleenex oh oh you
ch well he got it you know we didn't um
that was cheating
oh i didn't know there was rules to this
thing yeah
i didn't know we weren't allowed to do
research according to imdb
what are tom's trademarks oh
i would say uh uh sparkly blue eyes
charmingly genial and i think you know
people on the internet would
obviously remark on tom's pipes man
he's got he's got his main gun over on
the right
and then he's got a little backup with
the safety on over in the left you're
not far off from one of them
so um one is towering height
and one is muscular physique do i get
half a point no i think you should get a
point for
yeah for one of them robert learned to
play three instruments name
one piano uh no sir
it's a little visual clue tom
play the spoons
that it says i play the spoons can you
can you play the spoons
like how to what even no because it's
like a proper skill if you can play
those boots
even someone who can play i'm still like
i don't know if you
if you can be like into the juilliard
school of music mate if you're just
we're just rapping i think you should go
and audition mate and see if they'll let
you in
as a child robert was beaten
with which one of these implements that
is not the question
that's not the question